so what I wanted to do today is talk
through bringing some of the iconic
characters back to screen so from the
very very beginning with that how do you
approach casting those roles is point
number one only let's make a list of
actors who look like these iconic
characters well yeah it was there were
only two ways to approach it I thought
you know one was to have some kind of
digital avatar for these characters
which i thought was going to be a
disaster because whenever I see that
stuff although the technology gets
better all the time I'm always pulled
out of the movie and I'm always
evaluating the technology and I didn't
want to do that the idea that there
would be a little digital Danny Torrance
on a big wheel five minutes into the
film I thought we'd never recover from
that and so once that was eliminated as
a possibility then I looked at how we
were treating the hotel itself okay if
we're if we're revisiting this iconic
visual language of Kubrick knowing that
you know I would do my best to recreate
the hotel as best I could but that we
were still going to be doing our own
thing kind of within within its walls
how do I apply that philosophy to the
characters and and the answer that felt
the most honest and and I felt the most
respectful was to try to find actors who
had remind me a little of those iconic
characters just enough to kind of point
my memory in that direction but then
beyond that who would not be doing an
impression or a parody of those
performances who would then hopefully be
able to just inhabit the character so it
became about to calor in and not SCVNGR
others but with just enough notes to
kind of tilt my brain that way with that
in mind what is your note giving like on
set with them so you're never
essentially saying Olli remember when it
was done that way in the shining well I
mean the actors I mean talk about an
intimidating kind of job for them they
had already done the work of
scrutinizing every frame of their
counterparts work in the shining you
know that that was that was happening
whether we wanted it to or not and so I
never wanted to come to them and say oh
hey could you do it more like you know
so-and-so did it
it was it was more that okay thank you I
feel like the balance that you're
achieving between tribute and something
new is feeling like it's tilting a
little too much new or a little too much
toward the tribute and it was just all
about tiny microscopic recalibrations
but I gave very few notes very few notes
to those actors how acceso it's just I
know it's a huge fan of sorry I suppose
to see her nails all like this was she's
awesome starry eyes is awesome but she
it's uncanny kind of what she achieves
with I still can't quite get over it
yeah
as a big fan of the book I also wanted
to ask you what was the most difficult
thing to take out of this adaptation the
first thing that might have come to my
mind is maybe a certain relationship
that that's probably it yeah the amount
of real estate it would have taken to
properly tell that story of a Brazil in
eh I didn't have the time and the other
thing that I thought was powerful too
was that as cool as that story was the
absence of that lineage being in the
film allowed Abra stone herself to kind
of stand out even more to not make it so
that oh well in order to really kind of
be a character with the shining you have
to be Torrance you know it broadened the
story and opened it up and it supported
what dick Halloran said about how many
people in the world had the shining how
a few of them knew it and it made the
relationship between Dan and Abra I
thought there was something special
about it without that additional level
of connection